ils plus littéralement dans
l'appartement de wassim haussmann depuis
qu'un homme a percé la toiture à
plusieurs endroits le 8 août dernier des
bruits sourds et répétitif capte son
attention
alors qu'il monte sur le toit ce qu'il
découvre le sidère
il décide de capter la scène avec son
téléphone
il ne nous a pas été possible
d'identifier l'homme dans la vidéo
quelques heures après les gestes une
pluie diluvienne s'abat sur montréal
moi c'est mosman se désole que le
représentant de l'entreprise
propriétaire du bâtiment tristan des
hôtels n'ai pas fait les travaux de
réparation pour que l'eau 16 de ces
filtres et il affirme pourtant l'avoir à
maintes reprises interpellé pendant
trois semaines
ce n'est que le lendemain de notre
passage pour cette entrevue que le toit
est réparé wassim haussmann et trois
autres locataires dénoncent la
négligence de l'estrie un tristan des
hôtels il croit que ce laxisme
s'ajoutent aux stratégies déployées
depuis son arrivée pour les évincer
yves et le 7 juillet soit le lendemain
de l'achat crise tant d hôtel tente de
convaincre les locataires de résilier
leur bail il leur annonce que le
bâtiment est dangereux et qu'il doit
faire des rénovations
mais cette chantage qui le fait qu'on
allait se retrouver la maison barré est
expulsé par les pentes ou dans un
enregistrement audio et un courriel
obtenu par radio-canada tristan des
hôtels affirme qu il ne suffit que d'un
appel pour que les pompiers évacuent les
lieux ce qu'une vendeuse
reprises de joindre monsieur des hôtels
mais sans succès que j'aimerais prendre
rendez vous avec où
le groupe des quatre locataires refusent
de quitter leur appartement tant et
aussi longtemps que tristan des hôtels
ne se pliera pas aux exigences de la loi
un mélange d'espèces attendu harry caine
genre boivin espère quant à lui ne pas
être une autre victime de
l'embourgeoisement personnes ça s'arrête
et qui reste un camp des pauvres car
saint louis
c'était beaucoup
résultat les locataires ont fait
parvenir des mises en demeure à tristan
des hôtels dont l'espoir de faire
reconnaître leurs droits ici thomas
deshaies radio canada montréal